[SOUND] I love getting out
here in the environment.
It is so much better than sitting
in a stuffy office all day.
For the next part of this lesson,
you'll be setting up your environment.
Now the environment here consists of all
the living things and natural processes.
Your development environment
consists of all the software and
code that's available to either you or
the code that you're running.
The first two aspects of your
environment that you need to set up
are your browser and your text editor.
But before you go installing anything.
Hold on a second.
I want to clarify a few things first,
one,
you will be using a text
editor to write code.
When you read, text editor,
you might think about a piece
of software like Microsoft Word.
But our text editors for coding
are different, Word shows you rich text.
Rich text is formatted with fonts,
and styles and colors etcetera.
You want to write plain text for code.
This is just a set of ascii characters.
You should never, ever,
ever use Microsoft Word for coding.
The code that you write should not
be styled, it is just plain text.
Okay and point two.
Sometimes you might hear the term IDE
thrown around as a place to write code.
IDE stands for
integrated development environment.
Apple's Xcode and Microsoft's Visual
Studio are two examples of IDEs.
You can think of an IDE as
a text editor on steroids.
Besides allowing you to write code,
they will also compile it and
then run your code for you.
Beyond that they also have a number of
other features that you wouldn't find in
a text editor.
IDE's are incredibly useful, but
they aren't really ever used for
web development because of browsers.
Browsers will run our code and
we actually don't have to worry about
compiling anything, that's just
not a thing with web development.
I recommend staying away from IDEs for
the time being,
unless you happen to already
be familiar with one.
Okay, it's time for
you to set up your environment.